let's go to alex from orange county next
alex you're on the air
hey how are you doing david i'm doing
well
um have you um um read about the
sentences or
heard about the the latest simpsons um
recently
i have now i have to ask what's playing
in the background right now
my um that's my mom's um tv do you want
me to move or
it would be a yeah it will you and i
will be able to communicate so much
better if there isn't a tv going in the
background
the census yes we've covered the census
the u.s has
331.4 million people living in it
according to the census
um it is the slowest rate of population
growth dating back a very long time
and it will lead to two more
congressional districts for texas
and then there are some states going
plus one some states going minus one so
that's the census so far
all right dude how's my audio beautiful
all right so yeah i um i heard all about
that but my concern
is on the dexter scheme the districting
and the
um congressional seats and how the
gop might gerrymandered the way into
like
a house majority yes so my understanding
and tell me if this is your
understanding
is that the national census is used to
determine
how many seats each state has but it's
up to
each state to draw the lines some states
use a sort of nonpartisan districting
commission others it's more legislature
based is that your understanding of how
that works
yes yeah so it's a concern it's a
concern because you take a place like
texas
and i admit i've not looked at exact at
how texas will do this
you look at texas they you get two more
congressional seats
they could gerrymander the hell out of
them i don't know if you've seen dan
crenshaw's district
uh it's gigantic i mean it's just it
looks like a crescent moon it makes no
sense whatsoever
and that's why that district is a
republican district so i that's a huge
concern
yeah so um correct me if i'm wrong but
isn't
gerrymandering illegal well
the the the thing about that is it is
against
the it is against the law to
do it in a way where you were
deliberately disenfranchising
a uh protected class of people but the
the thing is proving that in court
that's a huge process and every once in
a while like i think there was a
decision in north carolina in the last
few years where
a judge found that's what they did
you've got to redraw
but that's a really expensive and long
process and so you can you can often
still get away even if that's what
you've done you can still get away with
it often for one or two election cycles
until until the legal system catches up
with it
okay um is there any way that
um even though we have the majority the
democrats have the
um are the leaders of the house and
slightly in the senate is there
any way that the democrats could like
prevent gerrymandering
i i mean so so democrats
in the house and senate and joe biden
could put together
in fact hr one may have some
gerrymandering related provisions in it
you could pass something like that at
the at the federal level
uh but then you will have lawsuits from
states
and then it'll have to be adjudicated
and
it's going to take some time so can it
be done
in time for 2022 i i don't know
it really is a state process and so when
you have the federal government trying
to regulate a state process you will
always have some states who say
that's outside of your purview and so
it's it yeah
the theoretical answer is yes the
practical answer of whether it can be
done before 2022 is a question mark
okay so um with all that um considering
how do you feel about the
2022 midterms i'm worried i'm more
worried about the house than the senate
is how i would say it right now
but i think it's a little too early to
say
if joe biden continues doing well in
getting things done
i think it's better if joe biden falters
and trump remains popular and gets
involved as a king maker
it could look pretty ugly for democrats
in 2022
hello okay
looks like we lost them i appreciate the
call very much and i'm glad to have
been able to answer at least some of
your questions